good afternoon on behalf of
T'Pol I would like to thank the
organizers
this conference as the world's largest
international police organization with
190 member countries Interpol's role is
to enable police around the world to
work together to Merck to make the world
a safer place cooperation is indeed
essential to fight organized crimes and
trafficking and if there is one area in
which working together makes perfect
sense it's certainly the fight against
the illicit trafficking of cultural
goods a phenomenon so complex and
difficult to combat particularly in
times of conflict as it is the case in
Syria and Iraq so destruction of
cultural heritage in this region has
reached alarming levels that is why it
appears clearly that working together is
today even more essential than ever you
can see on this map then one the 19 3%
of Sharon's cultural sites are inside
areas of conflict only then can the
recently adopted UN Security Council
resolution aiming to prevent the illicit
trade in a rocky and Sharon cultural
property be implemented UNESCO and
Interpol which are explicitly called to
assist as the member states in taking
appropriate steps to prevent the spread
have immediately highlighted the
necessity of strong cooperation Interpol
secretary general Jurgen stock
underlining the need for coordinated
global response as well in follow-up to
this resolution the UNESCO
director-general Irina Bokova met in the
beginning of March with a worldwide
director of compliance for sauce bees to
inform him about her initiative to
launch a global coalition of partners
involving key stake holders such as the
UN Office of Drugs and Crime Interpol
the UN sanctions committee and
stakeholders from the cultural
preservation and art market community in
this occasion she stressed that the art
market and the measure auction houses
were a key ally
effectively counter illicit trafficking
why focus on the art market players
because as you can imagine it's very
difficult to protect cultural property
in situ above all in the areas under
control by the Islamic state or other
terrorist groups at the same time we
only have five to ten percent chance to
intercept the objects once they have
been stolen or looted looted so we have
to act by seeking to narrow markets for
the illicit trade hoping that by curbing
the demand the supply would eventually
decrease and the business would become
less attractive to traffickers and
thieves the collaboration with auction
houses collectors museums Internet
platforms and various other art market
players is even more needed as there are
huge challenges to face in fighting
against illicit trafficking in control
good in the field in particular for law
enforcement maybe one of the most
important issue is the difficulty to
work in this area due to the very nature
of the trafficking cultural objects are
not inherently illicit which means the
burden on law enforcement is to prove
their fraudulent origins however the
traceability of an object can be very
complicated to determine starting with a
lack and often total absence of properly
inventories as it is the case for
archaeological objects the absence of
police register containing information
on professional transactions and
artifact descriptions is also a major
issue this tool is not required by the
majority of states which doesn't allow
for the possibility of the objects the
police register must be not only a
register of transactions involving
cultural goods in the accounting and an
intuitive sense of the term as it as it
is the case for united kingdom of
belgium it must also be a register that
serves to trace the good boy
and held by at market professionals and
its contents must be determined in light
of this objective listing different
information on the seller and the object
but as I said only a few states have
created an obligation for art market
professionals to keep a register of this
kind for instance in Europe Greece Italy
France however these registers are
considered by the police and even
investigators to be a crucial tool for
preventing the illicit circulation of
cultural good fellow to fulfil the
obligation to keep an accurate register
would be more ever evidence of bad faith
we saw that one of the main task of the
police consists in proving the
fraudulent origins of an object
determining bad faith on the part of the
dealer for instance is one of them into
achieving it so the task of the police
also consists in verifying that the
buyer of artwork exercises due diligence
with several criteria that should be
taken into account at the time of
purchase as due diligence is an element
that circumvents good friends good faith
among the numerous checks to be carried
out on the object the consultation of
database of stolen object in particular
particular Interpol's one and regarding
sia we are processing information on
1305 objects from the dear Atia museum
as well as all known items stolen from
other sites in the framework of this
collaboration with the ad market players
we need to promote and reward good
market behavior most of museums our art
dealers have for a long time code of
ethics or due diligence guidelines but
awareness of the importance of due
diligence still needs to be recalled to
help potential buyers to increase their
level of vigilance in this perspective
UNESCO signed agreements we
major auction houses and big word
museums under which they agreed to
refrain from buying any Syrian
antiquities that are not supported by
official certificate and proof of
provenance one more challenge for the
police and not the least is obviously
the internet with in particular the
difficulty to effectively monitor all of
these objects offer for sale without a
cooperation with an eye brokerage sites
it is nearly impossible to counter the
illicit sell of cultural objects through
the internet this is why Interpol UNESCO
an icon of co-signed a letter in 2007
setting out a checklist of basic actions
where the states are encouraged to
cooperate closely with internet sales
platforms some states such Switzerland
or state level institutions such as the
MLA in the UK have concluded interesting
partnerships agreements with brokerage
firms especially with ebay regarding the
situation in Iraq and Syria the ebay
general counsel says his team stays in
close contact with a number of outside
experts and law enforcement agencies to
stop trafficking on the online auction
site by identifying any misuse of ebay
and then take appropriate action to
conclude them it is obvious that the key
to fighting the trade in illicit
antiquities lies in cooperation and must
involve representative of the art market
but given the dramatic context in the
Middle East one must wonder if the legal
instruments currently in use to combat
the illicit trafficking of cultural
goods are well suited to the reality on
the ground and there is some debate
about whether we should better regulate
the market some countries think so as
for instance Germany Germany which plans
to tighten regulation of art and
antiquities trade proposing a new law
allowing only culture
good with an official export license
from their countries of origin to enter
his brothers as well in the US where for
congressman recently reintroduced a bill
into the house of representatives that
attends to restrict imports of cultural
property illegally traffic traffic from
Syria but such initiatives might be
difficult to implement given the
opposition of the up-market community as
in the US where political push for the
protection of seven antiquities might be
difficult to come by the German Ministry
of Culture also expects the influence
the influential antique dealers lobby
will try to put pressure on Berlin to
abandon its project one can effectively
estimate that new laws are not needed
and that museums collectors and the
market can police themselves in UK for
instance British politicians are also
not lobbying for new legislation
preferring asking for effective
enforcement of existing laws and for
more resources for the Metropolitan
Metropolitan Police art and antiques
squad but as I have said before it's not
only a question of resources but rather
a complexity of investigations in the
field this is why the adoption of
legally binding global measures to
counter the adoption to control the
illicit traffic appeals essential to
help narrow down trafficking channels
and markets and an odd markets are not
necessary opposed to more regulations
thus last month at the international
symposium on the illicit traffic in
cultural property organised by Interpol
the president of the french national
union of antiques dealers insisted on
the high interest of the police register
as a crucial tool for fighting the
illicit trafficking and that it should
be made mandatory and generalized in the
same way in light of the dramatic
situation we are facing in the Middle
East
we should strongly support the
strengthening of legal frameworks thank
you for your attention